hey crazies there's this thing that
teachers like to say in introductory
physics courses magnetic force cannot do
work but this is the science of silent
and we can't ever forget rule number
eight question everything before we get
into magnets though let's start with a
more fundamental question what is work
well you can't really define work
without also defining energy yes that
covered energy before in several videos
here's a summary of what we know energy
isn't anything by itself it's just a
number we assign that number to actual
thing like planet people or particles
the specific value of that number
doesn't matter whatever number it is as
long as there is symmetry across time
the total number never changes that's
the conservation of energy in any
practical sense all that really matters
is what energy does that's what work is
so let's put it this way energy is the
amount of stuff you can do work is the
amount of stuff you have done or will do
that's it but what do you mean by stuff
I mean anything that could exist or
happen lifting swimming climbing dancing
swinging waving running slithering uh
doing other things
boiling Lighting's chemical reactions
nuclear explosions or the very existence
of matter itself well that escalated
quickly
okay back to man if we want to know what
magnets can do work all we need is an
example of them doing stuff boom Magnus
doin stuff guess my work here is done
thanks for liking and sharing a second I
was reading and this is extra dynamics
[ __ ] it's not actually there magnet
doing your work just because it's in a
book it doesn't make it true
when textbooks a magnetic force can't do
work they have to do this convoluted
dance around kinda like this well it may
appear that the magnets are doing work
it is really just the electrons in the
magnet doing the work now regardless of
what objects or particles are doing the
work they're going to be doing that work
through a force work is always done by a
force in the direction of a displacement
that's how we get units of Newton meters
or foot
there is always a force so write in your
textbook is the idea the innately human
desire for simple rules the argument
goes a little something like this
imagine there's a proton moving to the
right suddenly a magnetic field is
turned on directed into your screen the
right-hand rule tells us the magnetic
force on that proton will be upward
perpendicular to the direction the
proton is moving in fact this
cross-product means the magnetic force
will always be perpendicular to that
motion since work is only done along the
direction of motion
magnetic force can't do it it seems like
a pretty solid argument until you stop
and think about it yes the magnetic
force on this proton in this specific
case isn't doing any work all it did was
change the path of that proton from
straight to circular however with
attracting magnet there is definitely a
magnetic force and that force is
definitely along the direction the
magnets move that magnetic force is
doing work maybe in order to you've been
kind of magnetic forces they're not but
I'll give you a couple more examples
anyway let's say you replace that proton
with a wire carrying an electric current
to the right that current will have an
upward magnetic force on it just like
the proton did but the current can't go
in a circle it's bowing to the wire so
the wire will just move straight upward
that's a force in the direction the wire
is moving and therefore work is being
done on the wire let's go even deeper
remember that proton the upward magnetic
force we found earlier is not the whole
story
protons do a lot more than just move
they also have another property called
quantum spin that can turn a particle
like a proton or electron into a tiny
magnet that tiny magnet can also respond
to the magnetic field causing another
magnetic force that can do work on that
proton in fact that's all a permanent
magnet really is a pile of lined-up
electrons acting as tiny magnets held in
place by a bunch of protons and other
electrons that's exactly how these
magnets do work that precious simple
rule is turning out to be more like this
magnetic force can't do work on a single
charge particle assuming you ignore the
particle spin it's kind of like that
English rule I before E except after C
unless you're a weird base for a
neighbor running a fiesty height
with that many exceptions is it really a
rule anymore so are you satisfied with
this answer let me know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like Rick Finn who are literally
making my life possible right now
thank you so much and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Bobbie
Harper who asked if we didn't have
Einstein's relativity to explain time
discrepancies in GPS satellites would we
call it dark time yep I'm pretty sure we
would
you